it's been a really um weird week
exciting week you know um you know
there's some good for the game of
thrones came out that was no but I got
get into it because there's you know
spoil but but I do want to talk about um
what you talk about George's feelings
about what your feelings about water
because Jessica just got married oh yeah
I do want to get into that I said yeah I
didn't want to get into that that's open
there yeah let's open gasps oh that's
what we're gonna open with yeah I just I
genuinely want to know yeah I know you
guys are friends and I know she had
thought about inviting Brice my feelings
went from here to here now that's like
it's worse than that it's worse than
that
it was busier this is what happens
Jessica
Kyla's friend he's she's my friend too I
guess had her wedding should have been
with the campers instead of Mike and um
you know I was sitting there in the
wedding I turn around I see Gilbert
there you know we he's on the white room
side which was [ __ ] that was so weird
why we only I was running a little late
and I realize when I said that was like
I'm the only Asian person on this side
but you know that's when you stand up
and you move they were about to start
walking and I was like oh I also saw you
from the other side but then I know that
I noticed that there were empty seats
and then you were like telling people
not to sit there so I didn't want to
yeah because um that's a whole other
issue because you know I got yelled at
because they thought I was gonna be late
to the wedding we just opened with my
point of view right I'm looking around
and some a couple goes can we sit there
no I'm saving this for
kalila and um you know her sister wait
you were there before yeah I'll tell you
why in a bit
no we don't they're getting into it the
paper I don't just listen to the patreon
patreon
yeah and I was just sitting there I'm
like where's Mike why are you continuing
then you don't need to set George up
with this in person he doesn't need to
know this but I need to tell a story
from beginning then I'm sorry that's how
I do okay there is no it is no end so
here's the thing turning around I go wow
you know the little girl comes and she's
doing the little bubbles flowers and the
music is starting and you know you know
Jessica's getting married once in her
life right once in her life you know you
would think that her best friends would
be them that's all so anyway um I think
I myself it's quick but you know yeah
but what George and in my head I'm like
George's has to be invited and it turns
out that he wasn't so basically this is
what happened George a couple of years
ago had feelings for Jessica deep deep
deep deep deep deep deep deep deep deep
deep feelings stovetop feelings and he
he molded over his head is like I am
gonna take a risk and I'm gonna be an a
male and I'm gonna get this alpha move
I'm gonna get this woman and he lunges
in for kids or whatever he does and she
[ __ ] just goes in your face nerd and
closes shop right in his [ __ ] face
and you got all hurt and [ __ ] he's like
oh no you know and he was hurt for a
very long time but then as all wounds
heal through time right and then the
wedding happened and the wound was cut
back open cut back open like you're not
even invited to the [ __ ] wedding
[ __ ] right you don't get my pause and
you don't get to go to the wedding
and then she opened it up and it's like
[ __ ] a thousand people [ __ ] in that
wound geez just took a dump right into
that wound your septic your septic now
but I missed you man you should deserve
to go and I I might have been you could
have gone
there were seats available so I'd like
you could have gone that's all I'm
saying
Bobby let me down how do I let you down
we're not doing that I have to say Bobby
let me down my ride to the wedding and
he never got there and you never pick me
up you never pick me up pick me up yes
she had a car car there kwinda uh no
your sister your mom everyone you were
with them right yeah but we were all
smudged all the girl fans have heard
this already let's George I might have
been the one to put the brakes on the
invitation because I didn't want to feel
any like a weirdness on a really small
wedding and I didn't want to see you cry
wait so it was weirdness for you not
Jessica no not for her she doesn't feel
weird about it this was just you she
loves these guys I was just like no
don't invite George Bryce maybe no I
mean I was inviting everybody I was like
yeah
George can stay that's why you hate me
for it no it's wrong I get why would you
now if you would have gone to the
wedding would you have been like bummed
sitting there no I would have been cool
he's already over it he where he was
happy about all the news because for me
it still I still feel it yeah we yeah we
would have been I mean from me
it would added it was humor and joy in
my heart great I would have laughed so
[ __ ] hard at him like while she's
saying I do I would take my hand out and
just [ __ ] give George the finger
while that's happening you saying I have
an objection and just flick oh yeah but
it was a pretty I love you know I've
only been to three weddings I know the
four third fourth wedding of four weeks
four weeks is so cute and pretty and fun
yeah look great yeah ours when we have
one baby it's gonna be legit yeah to
hear that
[Music]